Why have we spending so much time on 3-SAT in this unit instead of our usual problems,
vertex cover, clique, independent set, and shortest tour?
The thing is, there are very little know results for randomized algorithms for these problems here.
Of course, there are still many randomized algorithms for these problems here
especially for shortest tour, some also for clique and independent set,
but these are all algorithms where you don't know any guarantees.
You don't know if the algorithm will perform well or if it will produce a very suboptimal solution,
which of course leads to a question where you could ask,
well, in what cases might it be okay to use an algorithm that is randomized
and does not offer any guarantees?
And of course, I'll let you think about that.
Would it make sense to solve a problem with a randomized algorithm
where you don't have any guarantees if the stakes are low?
If no better algorithms are available, so the deterministic algorithms have failed
and there's no randomized algorithm known with a guarantee,
is it when you can think of any better algorithm, or is it when nobody you know
including yourself knows any better algorithm than a randomized algorithm without guarantees?